if you find yourself in an ambush it
wasn't a successful Ambush because if
you if you find yourself in it you're
alive you know yes
um but if you want to create an amazing
camera Ambush team you have to you know
you have to make them ambushers and with
ambushing you
figure out where all the uh
opportunities of not only successfully
doing what you need to do or in your
favor but also to escape with your life
you know we're not uh
we're not going to be received by
virgins in heaven we're not that's not
the type of mentality that we had down
there but uh
we start learning about some of these
things and also seeing you know cartel
forces apply some of these Ambush
tactics to the military or the federal
forces what is an ambush what are we
talking about so that's a surprise
attack with an asymmetry power kind of
thing there's a contingency somewhere
moving towards a place that you control
and own where you have the advantages
where they can't see you but you can't
see you can see them where they can't
predict you but you can predict where
they're going to pass go through you
know places where they forcibly have to
pass
uh places where they're predictable
places where you can not only predict
but also have a plan for yourself to
escape and exit that place so how do you
transfer Connor Ambush you turn into a
like a perfect ambusher that's how you
train for count around also always
trying to make sure you have more
information about other people you have
the element of surprise all of those
things and Musashi would say you know
your enemy know his sword you know but
basically that you know simplified
there's a lot of enemies around you in
Mexico there's a lot of uncertainty
right because it's well I guess that's
what route analysis is yeah you prepare
for the probable yeah and if the
impossible happens you're halfway out of
it hopefully you know and if you find
yourself in an ambush it wasn't a
successful one uh but you you uh as far
as our training and the kind of the
mindset my experience with it you the
adversarial thinking part of it has
always been a very powerful one I think
one that a lot of people ignore kind of
like leave to the Wayside
uh specifically in all conflicts out
there there's a tendency for a military
force or a conventional force of any
kind to be trained in a way where they
dehumanize the enemy yeah and when that
happens you become blind to the enemy
story it's his capability his story his
ability
uh you if you treat the other side like
an inhuman monster
it's hard to take notes you know so this
part of this is a radical empathy for
for
the quote unquote enemy at least for me
personally uh I wasn't I wasn't one of
the guys that would grab them and beat
the [ __ ] out of them put him in the back
of the van just tie them up and gag him
so you're able to see them as human I
learned that from my mother you know she
said uh uh nobody's against you at there
for themselves learn this and you will
you will make friends of enemies
she said that when I graduated and I've
carried that with me throughout my whole
career but isn't there then a pain of
killing another human as always
but there isn't again I apologize to go
back to Ukraine it's my only experience
of this kind of harshness and it is a
powerful experience there's a
dehumanization that happens
I suppose this is common in war there's
something like a video game aspect where
people are almost having fun there's a
humor and I think underneath that the
prerequisite is to see the enemy in the
same way you see the enemy when you play
Call of Duty you don't really think you
think of them as NPCs the bad guys the
Russians are called Orcs
in Ukraine I mean there's all kinds of
other names for Usos you know malandros
mugrosos like 30 people you know there's
always something over time those are
just words but over time it gathers a
kind of
um like a meaning to it that's more than
just the words Orcs they're less than
human yeah they're dirty they're too
dumb to understand the evil they're
doing or whatever whatever the it's
useful it's useful yeah it's part of the
program but like that's what I I've
talked to soldiers and
some of them do have stories of
momentarily remembering that there's a
human on the other side
I've talked to one woman
who's this really badass Soldier and she
saw this Really Brave soldier on the
other side
do something that
was almost stupid
How brave it was
and then she was trying to shoot him and
she missed
and she said she could sleep the night
after
thinking
why did she miss why did she miss
and then she thought she missed because
he was a hero and she had this brief
realization that there was a hero on the
other side like the other side is Heroes
yeah and then but then that quickly
disappeared yeah again but she had this
moment as a human being that rises to to
defend his Nation to defend his people
and he could be heroic on the other side
there are things that we're trained to
depress or
conceal or hide and kill in us when
you're trained for something like that
or when you're in Conflict Zone like
that and you hear the narrative
constantly being blared out that the
other side is a orc or you know whatever
whatever word you want to use but you
know we live in a day and age when you
can see uh Americans going off to Japan
and shaking hands with some of their
former enemies I mean some of us have
seen that
and how things change I think years from
now a lot of the stuff that we are
taking right now is of the utmost
importance won't matter anymore the
question is how many years the question
that's the question I asked of a lot of
people
in that part of the world
and a lot of them currently they're also
self-aware about it they're like I'm not
sure I trust my current feelings yeah
but the current feelings are
generational yeah like for decades I
will not just hate
the the leadership I will hate all
Russian people I can't understand that
on my side of my life experiences
because you know our war has been an
internal War you know amongst our people
our monster houses why that is the
propaganda it there's also a deep grain
of truth that there is a Oneness to the
people of that region yeah but people
will get very offended at that idea
because right now it's a very strong
nationalist borders but there is a
cultural history
that connects people I mean in some deep
sense we're all connected we all come
from Western Africa and then all came
from fish before then depending on your
uh the review of of light of history of
life on Earth
um
but there is a Oneness to us and often
you forget that in Conflict I had an
experience working
there was a friend of mine who took the
other path
uh and went to work for some of these
criminal groups
I was operational and I was
we saw a bunch of people in a gas
station parked
back then the main you know Moses
operandi that they had was that they
would impersonate or dress up as federal
police
and that's how they would move around
the city
we saw these Suburbans in a in a in a
gas station
and some of the guys were carrying on
our AK-47s you know and that's that's
not a standard issue firearm
so
you know we saw that and I got off on
foot and walked by
to try and get a
you know better sense of what was going
on I took everything off uh wearing
jeans and a t-shirt
and I got a whistle from one of the guys
uh that was there and my name was called
it was one of the guys that I grew up
with
redhead kid looked like El Canelo you
know
uh there's redheads in Mexico by the way
I think it's probably some of the Irish
that uh that betrayed the American side
during the last mexico-american war that
stayed down there had a bunch of kids so
it's probably from there love is
stronger than anything else this redhead
kitten when I say kid I mean he was my
age now to my eyes he's always going to
be younger now
he whistled
told my name
say hey
guess that geek out I'm like what are
you doing here it's like Oh She Gotta
just you know going home and she'll go
and get a taxi
it's like oh okay he'll walk as he walks
over it's like he has a plate carrier
with AK round uh magazines on his chest
uh AK without a stock on it
just carrying in his hand
he comes over and he hugs me I can feel
the uh the magazines on my chest
mind you I have a gun on me you know
tucked
and uh next Hill is buzzing in my back
pocket
as people are trying to you know figure
out what the [ __ ] going on
um he asked me small talk [ __ ] like hey
he's like what are you doing like what
do you work at I'm like I'm just looking
for a job you know he used to work at a
video store
so he's like I haven't seen you in a
while
uh I was so and so of your family good
and how's your family good
it's like yeah there's like this is an
interesting job you have he's like yeah
it's pretty good they pay us well and
get a you know you get a car you know
there's money
and nobody [ __ ] with you you get
respect I was like that's awesome you
know and if you want it can get you in
you know if you if you want that's like
Ah that's I'm too much of a coward for
that I told conversation like any other
yeah between two friends he hugs me
before I go
I just have something doing my I can't
remember what
and he says Hey in my ear I know what
you do for a living it's not a safe
place for you to be
and I walk off
a few moments later the Army showed up
and you
could feel the amount of rounds going
off from two blocks away
we came back with our guys
then it was it was over
so he didn't survive that
I looked through the bodies and the cars
that were left you know there was
bodies all over the place people left
there
it was a mess
they spent like an hour looking for him
the only way I could recognize him was
his hair
um I stayed with his body
all night there's a
there's a bridge
and Tijuana that goes over the river and
a place called La Mesa
and that's where the forensic offices
were
his body was taken there and I stayed
with his body until it was released
I told his family about it
because I knew them
in that aspect of you know us versus
them or they're the enemy and she like
that
you know my mom
told me those words nobody's against you
they're just for themselves so don't
make the mistake of dehumanizing anybody
and those roles could have been easily
reversed
I could have been shot in the face there
that aspect the conflict brings worth
let's say
bad guys good guys you know uh Heroes
villains you know I
there's an innocence to that that goes
away